you played an incredible game
congratulations how are you feeling now
that a bit of time has passed about your
eviction what emotions are you feeling
today
thank you very much uh for the congrats
and for the question as far as how i'm
feeling
now that a little bit of time has passed
um
i feel pretty good
of course you know you always want to
get further in the game but i knew
especially as soon as we secured final
six
i only wanted to win one way and
thus there was nothing about my gameplay
at the end there that would change so
right now i feel great about peace a
great amount of uh pride in sticking to
you know the principles i set out to and
we did some pretty amazing historic
things that i'm very proud of as well
how proud are you for how proud are you
to be part of season 23 big brother
knowing the focus on diversity and that
you are part of helping secure the
show's first black winner that is
incredible
i am
beyond proud of
and actually even beyond grateful for
being part of season 23 and we have this
focus on diversity and this opportunity
for the cookout to be possible and to
work together in this committed loyal
way that
we were able to secure this first black
winner of big brother and
it's funny because after eviction i was
able to check out my journal in my hotel
room as i'm waiting for the next part
and the very last thing that i wrote is
that i'm here to make history and that
was literally what we did uh what we
accomplished and to have a role in that
uh with some pretty amazing people
um
it's something that i'll cherish forever
and easily will
keep a special place of pride in my
heart
do you have any regrets about what you
said to xavier before leaving the house
or that entire situation
before leaving the house i was talking
to xavier about things that we had
discussed before so as far as regrets i
think that really just has to do with
clarification of the context because him
and i had spoken in depth about people
like a goku or like uh you know a kobe
bryant or like a t'challa
from black panther and these are people
who meet their competitors one-on-one
head-on when they don't have to
and
that is what we called uh achieving at
the highest level so we have to cook out
achieve this incredible display of black
excellence getting to the end and for me
coming into the house i was like i'm
gonna win that's what i'm here for as
soon as i saw the cookout i changed that
goal two i want to make sure that we
have the first black winner this season
as soon as i realized that that was
inevitable that was happening that we
were going to make it to the end of the
game
i had to reassess what is it that i
wanted this winner to represent and for
me i was like you know what achieving at
the highest level and doing things that
you have to do as opposed to things that
you know you
want to do just to secure your chances
of win
i decided that i was committed to having
the best players at the end of the game
and to me i think best players are
people who
make a move because
they have to so that's why i was like
you know big dear ozza
they didn't have any choice they had to
make moves because they weren't strong
competitors xavier was a pretty strong
competitor
and he told me that that's what he
wanted to do was sit with strong
competitors in that way
uh and i thought we saw eye to eye on
that as far as calling that objective
fact out that he chose a different path
than the one that we discussed
uh
i have no regression on that because
that's a true statement
as far as any personal offense
that of course would never be my
intention
if you came back for an alt-star season
what advice would you give to yourself
uh if i came back for an all-star season
i think the main piece of advice i would
give myself is that it's okay to play an
individual game
uh this season of course you know
prioritizing the cookout i had to make a
lot of moves that
could keep
five other people besides myself safe
in a way that i was completely loyal too
so that involved getting extra blood in
my hands
winning and
losing certain competitions
as needed and keeping some people in the
house as opposed to others
regardless of my personal relationships
and of who would actually be best for my
personal game
if i ever come back again
we've achieved that goal we have a first
black winner
i don't have to play
anyone else's game besides my own that
to me is pretty exciting because even
when i look at the players this season
there's definitely some different moves
i would have made if that was my mindset
and it would be really fun
to get to try that out
you